kind of an amazing moment on Sunday over
an NBC amor the sunday shows that people
used to pay attention to but no longer
do US Senator John Kennedy of Louisiana
was on there with Chuck Todd who was the
host and he made an argument that shot
Todd didn't like Todd didn't rebut the
argument not capable of that so instead
he did what so many do now he accused
senator Kennedy of being an agent of
Russia senator Kennedy you now have the
president of Ukraine saying he actively
worked for the Democratic nominee for
president I mean now come on I mean I
got to put up you realize the only other
person selling this argument outside the
United States is this man Vladimir Putin
so in a normal time we'd all recognize
that for what it was an embarrassing and
low moment accusing people without
evidence under the cover of journalism
of acting on behalf of a foreign
government there's a name for that
actually it's called McCarthyism we went
through a period where that happened we
learned nothing apparently the left
didn't that's literally what it is
McCarthyism but after calling people
racist it's the presses new favorite
baseless allegation of throw around more
evidence of that yesterday an MSNBC one
of their anchors and one of her guests
agreed that Senator Kennedy must be
working from Alaska this must be watch
this in defiance of facts intelligence
assessments reason Senator John Kennedy
was out peddling glad Amir Putin's
talking points
I mean look he's a guy who has a degree
from Oxford he's not an unintelligent
man yet he comes off as an addled
Russian asset on television I don't
understand the proactive work on behalf
of Vladimir Putin's Kremlin no I don't
understand either
yeah he must be disloyal Aaron Matta is
a journalist with the grey zone and the
nation and he joins us tonight Aaron
thanks so much for coming on so what do
you what do you make it I mean this room
seems to have escalated over the past
three years to the point where formerly
mainstream journalists are just looking
right into the camera and saying yeah I
don't agree with him he must be a
traitor to the country what do you make
of that what is so funny about the
indignation about Senator Kennedy's
comments is that he was pointing out a
documented fact there was you
meddling in 2016 and it's no secret
Ukrainian officials they leaked
information that expose some apparent
corruption by Paul Manafort and it was
consequential it led to Paul manna for
its resignation from the Trump campaign
and the stated intent of Ukrainian
officials was to weaken the Trump
campaign because they wanted to help
elect Hillary Clinton and you know it's
strange to see pundits pretending as if
that didn't happen and what they're
trying to do is conflate that with a
different theory by Ukrainian meddling
which is not proven it's true and that
is the one that Trump tried to put
forward in this phone call was olenski
where he appears to be saying that it
wasn't Russia that was behind the
hacking of the DNC and then it might
have been Ukraine it's true there's no
evidence for that theory and though it's
fair enough to point out that but what's
also ironic here is that the people who
are indignant about that claim by Trump
are accepting the claim that Russia
hacked the DNC even though there's been
no evidence yet there have been claims
by intelligence officials but those same
intelligence officials gave us the whole
scam that was the Trump Russia collusion
we can I stop you there since I do think
you're one of the more credible voices
on this and I should state I don't think
we agree on politics but you've really
follow this carefully at this moment
December 3rd 2019 we still don't have
actual evidence that the Russian
government hacked the DNC we've had
claims from a intelligence process that
was managed by John Brennan who has a
very sketchy history including being
caught lying to the Senate when the
Senate was investigating the CIA torture
program and we have an indictment from
Robert Muller but that but that
indictment is I've written about at real
clear investigations has serious holes
so you know Trump raises this theory in
this phone call with olenski that it
might have been Ukraine what I think
Trump should do and what I think all
journalists should be calling for is let
the public see for ourselves what the
underlying evidence is we've been told
by discredited intelligence officials
that it was Russia that intelligence
should be released
everybody can judge for themselves well
but I don't think you understand the
rules Ehrmann say if you don't take it
face value the claims of American in
telefilms present or retired then you're
working for
well you know yeah and the irony here
Tucker you know at times to sum it up
for me well just on this point right now
there is a huge scandal that you've
highlighted on your show which everyone
else is ignoring where intelligence
officials told us that Syria carried out
a chemical weapons attack now we have
whistleblowers that they'll at the OPCW
raising a question about that nobody on
either side is talking about that and
you know what shame on me for not doing
that story every night and thank you for
reminding me right that is a scandal an
actual one Ehrmann say thank you so much
thanks for having me